hi internet friends this summer has been  so much fun but we can't wait to get  back in the studio to make the best  possible season two just for you with me  drew  okay whoops i got caught up in a rhyme  there but more importantly we want to  feature you and that's why i've loved  pouring over all of your suggestions  with our suggestion box and this one  comes from lisa who sent us this  suggestion on instagram please announce  that you and adam sandler are making a  new movie well we don't have any plans  to yet but that doesn't mean that adam  will be stopping by on the show  after all he and i are very near and  dear to each other and we will be  collaborating for the rest of our lives  so  thank you so much for your suggestion um  we've also done a movie every 10 years  and we're probably going to be due for  one soon too so lisa i'm just going to  give you all the credit  for getting us back together and i hope  you like what we do